okay ready to go
thank you um so mr ryder we have
um taken into consideration all the
information that's been submitted in
front of us we've
um listened to all the evidence that
you've given us this afternoon
and the information from the
environmental health
service within trafford and our decision
is that we are going to serve a counter
notice
and not allow this event to take place
for the reasons of an inadequate risk
assessment and
on the grounds of public safety there
are
other reasons around around that
um of which you obviously have grounds
to appeal to the magistrates under the
licensing act
but obviously your events the chances of
getting a hearing before
the event would have taken place at the
end of august is probably not going to
happen under under current circumstances
one of the reasons that we've we've made
that decision is
around the risk assessment that you've
submitted what we
can't do within this environment this
afternoon is accept
you're saying well i'll change this or
i'll change that all we can do this
afternoon is take the information that's
in front of us
and because we can't put conditions in
place to enforce under a temporary event
notice
therefore we don't have anywhere to go
with it if it was a full licensing
application we could put other
conditions in place
but we don't have we don't have the
ability to do that under this process
so there's two things that we would
advise you to do
that if you are still looking to run the
event at the end
of august we would invite you to
probably engage a little bit
more closer with our environmental
health team at the council
to try and work on some of the issues
that have been raised this afternoon
around
the risk assessment but also around the
current environment
of covad in trafford at the current time
some of the work that our public health
team are going to
keep imperfection rates down and we're
very very strict around
what we are allowing and a lot of work
has been done
with our environmental health teams on
advising
bars restaurants events taking place and
we would invite you to engage a little
bit more closely within that
the other thing and one of the things we
haven't raised as part of the counter
counter objection is purely on the
grounds of public public safety
with an adequate risk assessment but
what we would do is ask you to
um resolve the issue over land ownership
this
this committee isn't the committee that
would give you
um permission to use the land so if the
land was council land
we don't have a role in allowing
permission that's through
another part of the council and you
would need to approach them
to get that permission and we suggest
that you get that permission in place
before you put a further application in
that isn't necessarily always a quick
process
the other thing if the land is owned by
the manchester ship canal which it might
it may be open by the ship canal is that
you would approach them
and see whether or not they would allow
it but i would get both of those things
in order
but the relationship with the
environmental health and new
understanding
the standards that we expect and also
permission to use the land
before you submit a further application
and that then would help
us with having a probably a slightly
better quality of information in front
of us
and it may be that their natural
environment and health are happy and
they don't put in an objection
and that you wouldn't have to come back
to committee that would depend on
on what's happened from there so that's
our decision this afternoon
to serve account notice you will get
that in writing okay we like to say
which then with the ability to appeal to
the magistrates court and if you do wish
to do that the licensing team will be
able to give you
some further information but have you
got any other questions for us at this
time
no i i totally understand and respect
your decision it's
like i said i'm used to doing this with
manchester council and i wasn't aware
who the correct bodies were to speak to
and like i stressed earlier as what i do
for an event it's
critical that my relationship with you
guys is is impeccable
i mean so moving forward it makes sense
now now i know everyone's faces that's
what i was going to say to you angela
are you the person now that i should
speak to in regards to any other event
because
generally speaking i will send these
risk assessments etcetera to people
before i put the tens in
but because i don't i didn't know the
relevant bodies at trafford that's why
it hasn't been done so i understand that
i'm moving forward i now know who to
speak to
um and yeah again thank you for the time
and i appreciate all the feedback and
i'll make sure that
everything's in a bit more detail moving
forward for anything that's going on in
traffic
and we wish you well with your business
mr ryder it's just like you play having
that relationship
so we can make sure that we all and we
all understand
what's the standards that are expected
but good luck with any other event thank
you
thank you very much yeah like i say it
is a very sensitive time and so
huge trust in me and what i do is more
important and especially because of my
fresh face i'm a new body
i could work for anyone or whatever you
don't know about do you so it's this is
the first step now and now
moving forward and all the steps to take
so yeah thank you again everyone yeah
good luck thank you enjoy the rest of
your day everyone
thank you see you later bye